ça bouge on somme leuze au lycée jules
verne de mondeville et la fabrique un
d'entre eux hors de son est en train
d'aider un autre breton gilles servat
qui sera en concert au carrefour
socioculturel de mondeville vous là ce
soir et demain parce que ce soir c'est
complet pour dire le succès de gilles
servat qui était un grand auteur poète
évidemment aux protons et la venue du
chanteur qui a commencé en 1969
s'inscrit dans le programme de la saison
culturelle de la maison des lycéens qui
ont pu assister à un concert ce matin on
à la blancherie
cher
d'où vous vient cette rage consent vous
de vivre
ben c'est parce que justement lorsqu'on
l'a trouvée y est plein de gens qui
diront pourquoi après tout journée marc
de fil c'est le monde est moche c'est
qu'est ce que vous avez à leur dire je
leur dis d'abord pensé à vous au lieu de
penser aux autres et de subir les autres
et c'est christ
ben non mais faut il faut être heureux
faut essayer d'être heureux quand on
peut quoi je sais pas c'est pas toujours
évident c'est sûr mais c'est pas faut
pas se décourager à cause du monde faut
s'encourager a changé le monde allait
faire la guerre penser des plus
longtemps une chanson peu changé de
mains ils s'en sont riches qu'au début
j'étais un peu sceptique et je me suis
rendu compte après infléchissant qu'il
ya des chansons - qui m'ont fait changer
donc je je n'étais pas comme ça avant
d'entendre des trucs de l'eau ferrer ou
de brassens ou des chansons du chanteur
comme ça puis après ouais hugues aufray
qui sont et dylan et les choses moi ça
m'a entraînée vers vers beaucoup de 2
seulement ouvrir beaucoup d'horizons
quoi
voir alors que la terre dit
merci infiniment d'avoir été avec nous
dans l'eau ça bouge on va tout de suite
retrouvé sa vie daniel ce que vous
intéresser au ténor au timbre et je
faire je fais un peu de chant d'opéra
mais cyrille dubois victoires de la
musique mais il est canet et bien
justement pour contre avec sabine daniel
là où ça bouge c'est sur france 3
normandie mais je suis avec un enfant du
pays cyril dubos ténors qui se produit
ce soir avec l'orchestré de caen ici au
conservatoire alors vous nous arrivait
de paris vous avez donné du mozart
d'après ce que j'ai compris un autre
mozart à dijon à venir et puis un
passage par la basse normandie pour du
bartok et du britten oui absolument
non je vais intervenir mois dans la
partie britten donc il ya deux pièces de
britten la simpl symphony et les
illuminations de rimbaud l'élimination
de rimbaud en fait ça fait partie des
pièces que britten a écrites en français
et donc c'est intéressant pour un ténor
d'interpréter 7 7 heures et pour moi
c'est un bonheur de pouvoir le faire
avec
avec leur caisse qui me connaît depuis
que je suis tout petit
je reviendrai faire quelques auditions
dans la saison comme je fais assez
régulièrement parce que pour moi c'est
important
j'ai reçu tellement de choses de la part
de la ville de la part de la maîtrise
que pour moi c'est une sorte de décharge
de bons procédés de que de maintenant
revenir et faire participer et faire
rayonner montrer le résultat un peu de
la formation j'ai eu
du coup là où ça bouge c'est sur soi
normandie et maintenant carmen en format
mini mes plaisirs maxi
carmen peut-il être réduit en poche et
le but de ce projet c'est pas possible
en tout cas même si on croit que ça
n'est pas possible on fait tout pour
contredire cela parce que ça fait partie
de notre éthique que de pouvoir
reprendre et des opéras des grands
opéras comme ça qui sont pour
normalement 80 musiciens peut-être un
peu moins pour carmen en face et 50
voire 80 sur scène et là on se retrouve
à moins de vingt musiciens et on est
plus en face on est sur scène avec avec
les chanteurs et on n'a plus que quatre
chanteurs et c'est là que ça devient
très intéressant parce que on est au
plus proche de l'opéra et est tombé sur
scène et tout le monde participe
on travaille avec l'orchestré régional
de normandie qui a eu l'idée de de faire
un jumelage avec différents lycées de la
région et qui sont donc des lycées qui
sont des lycées techniques pas des
lycées qui ont une vocation spécialement
artistique mais qui ont été sollicités
sur ce projet pour pouvoir intervenir au
niveau des décors au niveau des costumes
haut niveau du maquillage
tout a été orchestré on a les quatre
solistes les rôles principaux qu'on
connaît tellement parker et qu'on a
quand rêve de revoir j'en attends riz qu
on al tous les types de carmen à en une
heure et demie